hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in his analysis
the challenge of cultural relativism
James Rachel's is going to first set out
what he takes to be a central type of
argument made by those who espouse and
advocate for cultural relativism in
whatever form we happen to find it and
he talks first about a sort of very
specific argument that gets made and
I'll just run you through the two
examples that he has here's one the
premise is the Greeks believed it was
wrong to eat the dead whereas the
collations believed it was right to eat
the dead and the conclusion of that is
therefore eating the dead is neither
objectively right nor objectively wrong
is merely a matter of opinion which
varies from culture to culture and he
could have framed that as it's merely a
matter of cultural norms which vary from
culture to culture as well the next
example that he gives in this piece has
to do with the Eskimo or Inuit I says
that they saw nothing wrong with
infanticide whereas Americans believed
infanticide is immoral and the
conclusion to that would be infanticide
is neither objectively right nor
objectively wrong it's merely a matter
of a
which varies from culture to culture you
notice what the key connecting point is
there right acts whatever cultural
practice that happens to be is neither
objectively right nor objectively wrong
it is merely a matter of opinion or we
could say feeling or habit whatever we
want to call it we could invoke William
Graham summer and the folkways or
anything like that
Ruth Benedict any of the anthropologists
we'd like and we'd have the same
conclusion coming about we can't say any
of this is objectively right or wrong
it's merely something that varies from
culture to culture and for that reason
whatever is going to be right is right
only within a particular culture now
Rachel's generalizes this as indeed do
many cultural relativists those that he
has in his crosshairs in this this essay
into a more wide argument in terms of
its scope where we can say we have the
single premise and then we have a
conclusion the premise different
cultures have different moral codes and
then the conclusion which I've only
partially written up here therefore
there is no objective truth and morality
right and wrong are only matters of
opinion and opinions vary from culture
to culture so since they vary from
culture to culture whatever is right
varies from culture to culture as well
whatever is wrong varies from culture to
culture as well now we should be a
little bit leery of this to begin with
when we see one premise and one
conclusion if we know anything about
argumentation theory because you really
almost never as far as I could think
have a good conclusion coming a
supported conclusion coming from a
single premise so with that shows us
although Rachel's doesn't really talk
about this here is there have to be some
others supporting implicit premises that
are being assumed either on the part of
the person making the argument or the
person
hearing the argument in order for this
to be viewed as a good argument and
Rachel's points out that on its face
this is just a bad argument now he uses
the word unsound which is technically
not the right term to use in this a
unsound argument would be one whose
structure was in fact valid but the
premises are false in this case the
premise is true but we're not sure if
the conclusion actually is true and it
certainly doesn't seem to follow from
the premises we call this kind of
argument invalid why do we call it
invalid it's supposed to be a deductive
argument and just on the basis of its
structure the way inference is coming
about the the premise doesn't
necessarily lead to the conclusion
notice Rachel's says in this that the
conclusion could be true but the way
this is set up this doesn't this does
not provide us good reasons to think
that the conclusion would be true
because of the argument structure and
evidence being provided and he calls us
the cultural differences argument he
says to many people it's persuasive but
it's it's not a good argument so he
gives us a counter example he says
consider the example of the Greeks and
the Galatians the Greeks believed it was
wrong to eat the dead the collations
believed it was right does it follow
from the mere fact that they disagreed
that there is no objective truth in the
matter it doesn't follow he says it
could be that one practice in fact was
objectively right or wrong and one was
simply mistaken now we would need some
sort of frame of reference in order to
say which one was objectively right or
wrong but here the the relativist is
going further and saying we can't
possibly determine whether one of them
is right or wrong except within its own
field Rachel's then invites us to think
about a similar manner he's drawing an
analogy here he says in some societies
Polly people believe the earth is flat
as a matter of fact even within our
Western highly technological society
there is a Flat Earth Society and there
are apparently more and more people
belonging to this year after year so
even in our own complex Western late
modern society there's some people who
believe that the world is flat says in
other societies such as our own people
believe that the earth is a sphere by
the way just as a side note the
medievals did not think that the world
was flat you can see this by actually
reading medieval thinkers like Ansem or
Thomas Aquinas who casually mentioned
the globe of the earth right so now how
do you tell who's right or who's wrong
about this but we don't don't worry
about so much the decision procedure but
would you say that it's just a matter of
opinion the over here they think the
world is flat and because they think
it's flat it is flat over here they
think the world is round and because
they think it's rounded is round that
doesn't work and so he says we wouldn't
buy that we would never draw such a
conclusion because we realized the
members of some societies might simply
be wrong
when it comes to geography and he
invites us to draw a similar conclusion
when it comes to ethics or moral codes
or practices that that people buy into
this is not the strongest argument on
its face that Rachel's is making against
cultural relativism here but he is
pointing something out that if this is
going to be a good argument something
more needs to be added to it and it's
not generally being added to it then he
makes another very interesting
counter-argument himself in the next
section what follows from cultural
relativism he says well let's pretend
that cultural relativism is true what
would follow if it really was true he
says here's the three consequences that
would follow from this one would be that
we cannot say that the customs of other
societies are in any way inferior to our
own or rather we're free to do so but
we're basically just asserting ourselves
and there is no validity to what we're
actually saying and there's no reason
why they should listen to us or anybody
else should listen to us
we're just babbling essentially so long
as we're outside of our little sphere in
what we're judging now that could be
problematic he says that this is indeed
one of the main points stressed by
cultural relativism so the cultural
relativism yeah exactly
so shut up about you know American or
European or Western society or pick
whatever you have being better than
anyone else if you're Chinese quit
saying Chinese society is better than
anyone else now he points out if that's
the case we would also be barred from
criticizing less benign practices so he
brings up tienamin square we want to say
that it's not okay to crush dissidents
and send them into hiding for decades on
end or if we could think about other
things going on more recently that we
might condemn this would mean that we
couldn't condemn them we could condemn
things within our own society but we
couldn't condemn anything outside of our
society we're gonna say well that's
that's just their norms what else we
also can't criticize our own moral code
if that's the case so maybe we can't
actually criticize anything within our
society he says relativism suggests a
simple test for determining what is
right and what's wrong
all we need to do is ask whether the
action is in line or the code of the
society in question so you know although
the caste system has been you know long
sense legally banished
in India it still exists it's actually
such a problem that Britain recently had
to enact laws for workplaces saying that
you can't that that you cannot
discriminate in British companies and on
British soil you cannot discriminate on
the basis of caste because it is such a
pervasive part of culture so he says
suppose a resident of India wonders
whether the country's caste system is
morally correct all they have to do is
ask whether this conforms to the
society's moral code and if that was a
case there never would have been any
sort of getting rid of the caste system
because it was part of the country's
moral code goes all the way back to you
know ancient religious texts and customs
and all sorts of other developments and
we could think of many other things like
that in our own Western society where
nothing would ever have have been
changed we would simply consult you know
what are the norms and then we'd have to
follow them the mere fact that we can
actually call the norms into question
seems to be a problem for the cultural
relativist position the third issue
which is very interesting is that if we
accept cultural relativism we can no
longer talk in terms of progress or
declined we can talk about changes but
we can't say that anything actually
constitutes getting better as opposed to
getting worse in terms of moral norms so
what would that preclude that would mean
for example that we would not be able to
say that the civil rights struggle on
the whole was a sign of moral progress
or certainly the civil rights
legislation as well we would not be able
to say things like we ought to reform
our prisons so that they're more humane
because you know it's just our norms to
treat prisoners badly for the most part
here in America by comparison to say
European countries or we could talk
about drug legalization perhaps it's
progress to legalize certain drugs to
decriminalize them but we wouldn't be
able to say that from the perspective
that is afforded to us of cultural
relativism so here's the upshot of this
[Music]
he says that these three consequences
have led many people to reject it
because cultural relativism implies that
the judgments that we make would make no
sense cultural relativism itself must be
wrong there has to be something wrong
with it so there's an argument here for
cultural relativism and then there's
Rachel's to attempt to rebut that
argument by providing counter arguments
you